it is Thursday which means we have the
latest unemployment report from the
previous week the numbers are staggering
once again an additional 4.4 million new
people filed for unemployment benefits
last week these are what we call initial
claims when you first file for benefits
remember that we get the numbers on
Thursday from the previous week so let's
look at the total numbers since the
start of the corona virus pandemic
remember that before the pandemic the
most jobless claims we had had in one
week was in 1982 I believe and it was
somewhere between six and eight hundred
thousand I don't remember the numbers
exactly but compare them to the numbers
from the last five weeks the week ending
March 21 3.3 million new jobless claims
week ending March 28 6.8 million April
4th 6.6 million April 11 another 5.2
million and then the week ending April
18 4.4 million so this is now a total of
26 point four million people who have
filed for unemployment since the start
of the corona virus pandemic we believed
that the labor force was about a hundred
and fifty eight million right before
this started so what this means is that
nearly 17 percent of the country has
lost their jobs in the last five weeks
so a few different things first of all
the scope and magnitude of this these
are job loss numbers that would have
been inconceivable four months ago four
months ago someone said how would the
economy react to 17 percent of the
country losing their jobs it's
cartoonish these are cartoonishly huge
numbers no one alive today lived through
anything like this in their working
lives okay we have now lost more jobs in
the last five weeks than the total
number of jobs created since the Great
Recession okay so let me clarify those
numbers during the 2008 recession we
lost 8.7 million jobs since we started
recovering from that recession 20 2.4
million jobs were created total since
2009 okay we now have lost more than
26 million in the last five weeks the
entire jobs recovery from the recession
including the jobs created under Barack
Obama and the roughly six million that
were created under Donald Trump up until
this started all of those jobs are gone
so that's number one the magnitude of it
number two every one of us that has a
job should be very grateful because the
situation is truly horrifying that that
that's just an interjection even people
who have lost jobs and want to go on
unemployment insurance or having trouble
so it's not as simple as well you lose
your job the government's going to bail
you out there are states that may soon
or not run out of unemployment money
many people just aren't hearing back for
weeks
many people filed or attempted to file
weeks ago they haven't gotten a dollar
yet because the systems are so
overwhelmed truly dystopian now in terms
of the outlook even if new claims slow
down and they probably will right so we
may go down to only 3.8 million new
claims next week and maybe 3.4 the fault
right you could have a declining growth
rate the total number of people on
unemployment could continue climbing in
total over the next few months depending
on the spread of the pandemic we could
have 30 million we could have 35 million
I spoke to one economist who thinks by
July depending on how things go we could
have 40 million people on unemployment
benefits can the states even afford that
it's not clear now you have a contingent
from the right that says just open it up
and it'll all get resolved because the
economy will restart doesn't seem to be
the case because unless and until you
deal with the pandemic when you you can
open a restaurant you can open a barber
shop you can open a nail salon doesn't
mean that people are going to go it's
not going to fix this if here in
Massachusetts right now salons and
barbershops opened up I'm not going to
get a haircut nobody have spoken to is
going to get a haircut
what good is taking someone off of
unemployment benefits so that they can
stand in a barber shop Clippers and
scissors in hand with no customers
coming in so with history as our guide
we know that the one way to deal with
this is to deal with the virus itself as
quickly as possible now there's new
research there's new studies that are
suggesting that lock down or not the
curve is roughly similar in in growth
rate not in absolute numbers and that is
something we should
thinking about I'm gonna be studying
that tomorrow over the weekend and I'll
come to you with information about that
on Monday but opening business is just
so people can stand there without
customers is not a path it's not a
strategy it's not really anything states
can't really open economies people can
open economies and despite the astroturf
protests which we'll talk about later
today most people right now aren't
willing to go and pretend everything is
normal even if a bunch of businesses
start opening up very important to
understand that today's program is
sponsored in part by the galaxy series
which is a series of three books written
by a really great author I thought and I
would call the genre sort of political
science fiction I've really enjoyed the
books it looks at the future it explores
what could happen to Planet Earth if we
stay on our path environmentally it
deals with space travel it takes a sort
of deep dive into political psychology
and it's a really intriguing sort of
dystopian look at the future the stories
are told from a perspective that I think
people in the audience would really
appreciate and there's a ton of really
excellent art work also that accompanies
the books I read a lot of books in this
genre and I'll tell you these books are
very well written the plot the
characters are compelling if you're
someone who likes politics and sci-fi
you'll really like these books again
it's the galaxy series check it out for
yourself for a limited time we have a
special deal set up where my audience
can get each book for just 99 cents go
to david pakman.com slash galaxy